There are people that would really rather hang out with a bear
than a man. I am loving this bear discourse
but I just have an issue that
it's not appropriate in an Australian context
cause we don't have bears.
So I'm going to pre appropriated for an Australian flora
fauna landscape. I would not live with a man.
I refused to live with male housemates
because it was really important to me that in my home,
given what I do that it was a really safe filling space
and where I was living,
I just couldn't guarantee that there would be a man
who I would feel entirely comfortable around with
living with. So I chose not to live with men.
However, I chose to live with three Sydney funnel web spiders,
which if you don't know what they are,
they are one of the most deadly spiders in the entire world
and people die when they get bitten by these spiders.
They're really, really big and they look like cartoon spiders
like they have those scary eyes.
I had two of them living in my shower
watching me shower everyday and one of them living in my kitchen.
I do not advise doing this.
This is not a smart thing to do.
But I would have preferred
and did prefer
to live with three Sydney funnel webs than with one human man.
Eventually I decided that I did need to eradicate them
because I was scared that would Bite my dog um,
but yeah, I would prefer to encounter an eastern brown snake on a hike
in the bush than a man
the reason being that eastern brown snakes tend to keep to themselves
and not like
walk behind you in a creepy way or try to engage you in conversation
um, unless you kinda step on them or intimidate them in some way
they're gonna leave you alone unlike most men
the other reason that I prefer to encounter an eastern brown snake
which is a very deadly snake
is because if I was to get bitten by an eastern brown snake, um,
I could present at hospital with my very clear wound
and then no one would ask me like
why were you there? Like why were you hiking?
Like what what were you wearing?
Were you your shorts were too short?
Um, were you drinking?
Were you drunk? Like were you asking for it?
Like what did you do to like provoke the eastern brown?
Like maybe you were sending the eastern brown like mixed signals no,
no one's gonna ask me that
they're just gonna like
provide me with the medical support that I need at that time
no questions asked.
I would also prefer to surf in the middle of the ocean with a shark
than with a man because if you've ever surfed with men
you'll know that they scream at you
they get really intimidating
they yell that you're on their Wave
and they generally just like take over the entire surf break, um,
without a thought for anyone else.
It's a really intimidating environment for women to go into
and yet sharks mainly just keep to themselves.
Most of them aren't dangerous.
Um,
they could be, but they're generally like not.
Um, and they'll just like be there and swim away
and you probably won't even notice them unlike men.